Cool. Yeah, I hope everyone had a nice
coffee break. Um, so today we'll be
talking about the very interesting topic
of how we shipped security agents in
production and how we leverage
guardrails along the way. Um, so
specifically we're going to focus on two
agents. Um, a threat modeling agent and
a security routing agent. Um so you know
we could probably use a little bit more
creativity in those names but the core
problem we're trying to solve u with our
security team and maybe you know you've
seen this in your security or as well is
you know too many security reviews and
not enough human time and also getting
our users the answers to the questions
they need efficiently.
So here's our agenda for today. Um, but
very concretely we're going to dive
into, you know, the architecture of
these agents, how we approached quality
and measured accuracy, how we met users
where they were throughout the process,
and finally finish off with some
learnings.
And as mentioned before, uh, Sid and I
are software and security engineers at
Stripe.
>> Yeah. So, there are two main problems we
tried to attack using AI for security at
Stripe. One of them being security
routing. And what I mean by that is how
do we get users given so many different
security teams to the right one minim
while minimizing development time and
friction for security engineers. Another
problem we were trying to solve is with
threat modeling and what I mean by that
is with the rise of use of AI and the
software development life cycle. How are
we attacking this increased demand for
security guidance? And of course there
are a bunch of different challenges
associated with creating agents for the
two. One of the main challenges we
focused on was hallucinations. As we've
all come to know and love, AIs can and
will hallucinate. And these
hallucinations can actually end up
recreating the problem we're trying to
solve in the first place. For example,
with security routing, if we're routing
people to the wrong team, then we're
having to get security engineers and
developers reinvolved in this whole
process of getting them back on track,
recreating the problem.
Cool. So, with that context in mind,
we're going to dive into how we approach
the design starting with our threat
model agent. So one important
consideration we had to make in the
beginning was will this agent be more of
a longunning right async process in the
background or do we need to be more
conversational and faster in its
response time and that way we could look
at the you know trade-offs between hey
do we want to focus on accuracy and
processing rather than having to get a
very fast response. And so in our case
we actually opted for the ladder. You
can imagine we have a security review
ticket come into our queue and our agent
can take the time and processing time
that it needs to get back a response. Um
so this led us to take a modular multi-
aent structure. So on the right you can
see that we have an orchestrator agent
which has a couple parameters it takes
in um based on our intake form for
example our security review category. It
then feeds it into input agents uh
relevant security agents and then lastly
our output agents. So our input agents
the main goal is to get the relevant
additional input context that come you
know in your tickets. Sometimes they're
Google doc links you know slack threads
additional information that's relevant
that we want to include for our security
agents. And with our security agents we
try to take a very specialized uh
targeted approach. And so what I mean by
that is you know imagine we have a third
party you know security view agent. We
wanted to make sure that it was specific
to that category. And when we're
balancing determinism versus
non-determinism, we believe that there
was a core baseline of required
questions that was required to, you
know, make any third-party security
review complete. Things such as, you
know, what's the data sensitivity
involved? What's the data transport
protocols, right? What's the odd story
there? And so this doesn't necessarily
limit what the agent could, you know,
review, but it had to at least include
information on these points to get a
complete, you know, successful threat
model. The other decision that we made
was to be very intentional with the
tools that we used. And so one that I'll
explicitly call out is having great
internal guidance tools. You know, LM
are good at giving more generic security
context. But what's really powerful is
having, you know, company specific
guidance that aims to, you know, provide
risks and mitigations that can be
actionable.
And then lastly, these are fed to our
output agents. And you can we'll talk
about this a bit more later on but you
can imagine there's different audiences
that want different formats. Now why did
we take this more you know sequential
agent approach and the reason behind
that is we wanted more predictable
behavior for certain areas. We always
want the input agent to run first
security agents you know try to do
analysis in parallel and then last your
output agents to run. We found that when
we gave, you know, our orchestrator
agent too much agency, it wouldn't
always run the relevant specialized
agent that we wanted it to. Now, this
doesn't mean we're stuck, you know, with
this sequential approach. We're thinking
of doing a more hybrid one where similar
to how we approach the core baseline,
you know, maybe we have a core baseline
of security agents we need to run based
on human input, right? But if it's a
very vague category, we want to layer on
top agency from the orchestrator agent
to say, hey, maybe you know a web
specialized agent's applicable here.
>> Yeah. So for the security routing agent,
we decided to take a different approach
instead of the sequential agent
structure, especially given the fact
that any question uh could be dealt with
for security routing. So instead of
using a more sequential structure, we
used a initially we started with a
one-step LM call. give it no access to
tools, no access to the internet or
anything local at Stripe. Instead, we
just started with a simple prompt that
had a bunch of pre-contextual
information about the various security
teams at Stripe. And um while this ran
really fast, you can see that it
probably didn't work for a lot of
reasons. One of the main ones being that
it's not going to know about any
internal terms or documentation used at
Stripe. So, if the user's question was
relating to any software development
that was using any of those internal
tools, terms, etc., the AI would often
hallucinate. We then decided to shift to
a more agentic structure uh giving it
access to tools to compile its own set
of information. So we took this one-step
prompt, took out all this contextual
information about the various security
teams and instead encouraged it to
research on its own. At the beginning,
we provided it with as many tools as we
could to just get a complete picture.
And this worked great for accuracy
reasons, but for performance reasons,
the agent took around 10 minutes to run,
hardly conversational at all. So to get
it down further, what we decided to do
is try to get the tool set down
specifically to as to be as minimum and
as concise as possible through a slow
and iterative process of just taking a
set of baseline questions we knew the
answer to, testing the agent, plucking
tools one by one, retesting the accuracy
and ensuring it's not changing too much.
We were able to get down to about two
tools and a runtime of around 30
seconds.
>> Great. So, you know, with all this
discussion around our agent
architecture, how did we know that it
was the right choice and if it was the
right choice that when we make changes
that they're actually improving the
agent? So, starting with threat
modeling, as many of you may know,
threat modeling is often more of an art
than a science. And there's not a single
right answer, right? There's not a
single right threat model. So, when
we're looking into different ways to
score the threat modeling, we were first
approached with, hey, can we do
deterministic matching? And this didn't
really, you know, fit the bill. When we
tried to compare MITER categories, we
found that there would sometimes be
wrong labeling. The agent would have the
correct risk, but in two different runs,
it would label them as, you know, one
category and another time in another
category, even though the risk itself
was being communicated correctly. Other
meth more simpler methods like, you
know, keyword matching didn't fit right
as well. So this made us turn to you
know what really matters and what really
mattered was the semantics and meaning
behind the risk being conveyed and so we
turned to LLM as a judge. Now, one
question that comes up with LM as a
judge is, you know, do we trust the LM
to evaluate the threat model in
isolation and it's a bit of a cyclical
dependency because, you know, the whole
reason why we're doing this evaluation
is because we don't trust the LM to give
us 100% correct threat model, right? So,
why are we going to allow the LM to
evaluate and trust that'll give us 100%
correct evaluation? So to address this
and take a more balanced approach, we
wanted to have humans involved and take
advantage of what humans are good at um
in creating gold and standard based test
cases right based on past security
reviews and also what LM are good at
which is semantic reasoning. And so in
this flow what we tked the LM with doing
is hey given this expected output on our
goal and standard test case what are the
semantic equivalences between that and
our actual output from our agent right
so looking at the risk the mitigations
based on semantic equivalence and we
felt like this was the right approach to
get to the right meaning behind the
risk. And so at the bottom you can see
how that sort of you know looks in our
iteration model where we have a golden
standard test case with its
corresponding um actual agent output.
And we would iterate on that based on
the scoring accuracy to get to you know
an accuracy that we were happy with that
improved the agent um before sending out
right our pull request um in the offline
mode.
>> Yeah. So with this evaluation pipeline
in place, how exactly did we take
advantage of it? Well, we first started
and looked at our base prompt and found
that there were a few test cases within
our golden set that were particularly
low. We used these test cases to guide
improvements in our prompt, not
specifically by overfitting it, but just
by encouraging the prompt to act more
like a security engineer. For example,
one of the specific things we did was by
giving the prompt specific security
domains to always consider such as
authorization and single sign on. This
guided improvements to get us about 10%
and 10% increase in accuracy. One of the
other things we used the the UVEL
pipeline for was to select the best
flagship LM model for our threat
modeling agent. Specifically, we did
this by creating a mega data set using
copies, individual copies of our golden
set standard cases. The reason we
duplicated our test cases was to really
eliminate the non-deterministic nature
of AI between runs. By using the simple
process, we were able to uh test and
automate um testing each baseline LLM
model and swap it with the one that
performed the highest. This led to
another increase of about 10% in
accuracy. But finally, one of the most
one of the largest impacts from this
evaluation pipeline is the fact that it
really gave us confidence in the changes
what we we made to our prompt. For
example, take a look at the prompt you
see on your right where it says you're a
security engineer and then describes how
to properly format a JSON. On an
individual run without the evaluation
pipeline, things might look great. We're
outputting a correctly formatted JSON
threat model and we're also giving
security advice. But what the eval
pipeline is actually showing us is that
overall accuracy has gone down 10%.
Because the agent is focusing more on
how to properly output a JSON and less
on actually providing accurate security
guidance. So this eval pipeline really
gives us confidence in the changes that
we make to our prompt in the sense that
they're applying generally speaking
rather than just in minute cases.
Yeah. Uh so the evol pipeline for
security routing was a bit different. It
relied more on user provided feedback
given the open-ended nature of the
situation. Instead, we relied on
releasing to a small bubble of users,
iterating on user feedback, increasing
that bubble and so forth. Specifically,
we started by releasing the agent just
to be accessible via a web page just so
that our team members and anyone across
Stripe internally could access it. Then
taking this feedback and getting more
confidence in it, we wanted to test how
it handles user situations. So we made
it invocable in Slack to really test uh
context dependence. Finally, after
iterating on that phase, getting uh
confidence in it, we released it to all
developers across Stripe in the internal
chat UI for agents at Stripe. This was
really to meet developers where they
are. And then of course we also relied
on demos and outreach to again just get
as much feedback as possible from direct
users. Again, given the open-ended
nature of security routing.
>> Cool. So speaking about meeting users
where they are, we wanted to highlight a
couple of key actions that we took as a
team to make sure that users were you
know kept involved in the process. So
the first one is phase rollout. So this
one we'll be talking about in the threat
modeling context where we chose a
specific subcategory of security reviews
that we believed agents would be able to
perform well at. And what that means is
choosing security reviews that had very
similar risks and very similar
mitigations. And we believe this more
constrained domain made it better for an
automation setting. Once we had our
established subcategories of security
reviews, you know, we built out our
agent architecture and ran this all in
shadow mode. During this process, we
continually iterated using our
evaluation pipeline discussed before to
get to an accuracy that we're confident
in. Now, you might ask, you know, what
how do we determine what accuracy
threshold and I think this really
depends on the behavior of your agent.
You can imagine if your agent is
directly sending these threat models,
these risks and making super noisy, you
know, integrations into your engineering
teams, if you don't have a very high
accuracy, you know, you're going to get
a lot of slack. Those engineering teams
are not going to be happy. Versus if we
add in a human in the loop where maybe
the agent gets you 90% of the way there,
right? But you still have that one last
step of a human confirming those threats
and mitigations are applicable. we can
go for you know slightly less accuracy.
So we ended up with the latter approach
aiming for around 80% in the beginning
and then continuing to iterate on it
once it became visible to our users. Now
speaking about our you know consumption
methods while the semantics first you
know risk representation was gate great
for our evaluation model. We found that
you know other audiences wanted
different formats. For example humans
wanted a more summarized format while we
had threat modeling tool that wanted
more structured format for metrics. So
we opted for a MITER framework there.
And then lastly, we recognize that the
threat modeling agent doesn't always,
you know, output something that's fully
complete, right? Especially for more
vague categories. We want to have the
option to continue the conversation in
our conversational agent. And the focus
here was making sure that the input
going to the conversational agent had
the necessary context and almost proof
of work from our threat modeling agent
to make it successful. Then lastly, we
recognized that, you know, we're not
always operating with perfect
information. And when we're missing
information, we shouldn't have the
expectation that threat model should be
100% complete, right? The threat model
agent should call out where the missing
information is that the status is
unknown and set the security engineers
up to, you know, bring up to the next
step, which is, hey, based on this
question, if we can answer it, we can
tell if this risk is mitigated or it's
not.
>> Yeah. So, there are a lot of great
learnings we took away from this whole
process. One of them being about Alpha
Evolve. If you don't know what Alpha
Evolve is, it's this Google AI deepmind
tool that essentially evolves algorithms
or in this case prompts using a process
similar to natural evolution. So in this
case, let's work on an example. We take
our base prompt, we make a bunch of
different variations to it, adding a few
words here, maybe changing the wording
here, and then take the one that
performs the best score through our
evaluation pipeline and take it to the
next round. We repeat this process until
we get the truly most evolved form of
the prompt. While this sounds great in
theory and works great in a lot of
computational and mathematical cases
where there are only so many
permutations of things you can try, in
the case of language because of how
open-ended it is, we found that it
didn't really work great, especially
within the realms of the cost we were
able to handle. For example, in this
case, all it did in variation one was
add two words, not really semantically
changing the prompt at all. In the
second variation, it just paraphrase the
entire prompt. Again, not adding any
semantic changes that would actually
hopefully guide improvements. So in this
case, we found out that alpha evolve
didn't really work great. Another
learning we had is that we found out
that humans in the loop aren't optional.
And this really goes great with what
Jeffree has been talking about in the
sense that we have all these LM
generated threat models and a relative
amount of confidence in it. But because
we don't have that full confidence, we
don't want to actually act on these
results. We want a security engineer to
still review these AI generated threat
models and push forward threats that are
actually relevant and of course deny
those that aren't. Um, another learning
we had goes back to the JSON example,
which is investing in your eval pipeline
early. And what I mean by that
specifically is that if we had just not
invested in our eval pipeline early and
instead guided focused on just getting
those edge cases correct and etc., we
would have ended up with some big
garbage mess of a prompt that maybe
scores great in some very weird cases,
but generally speaking focuses too
heavily on specifics and uh, generally
performance will go down. Another
learning we had is that agent
architecture really depends on the task.
We saw that a multi-step child agent
architecture worked great for the threat
modeling agent. For the security routing
agent, a more simplistic undetermined
structure really worked. There's not
really a one-sizefits-all here. And then
finally, one of the most important
learnings we had is that garbage input
really means garbage output. And of
course, we don't want our threat model
agent to produce garbage output. We want
it to handle all threat models uh like a
security engineer would. Take this
example garbage input ticket where
there's not many specifics at all.
Initially, our LLM would end up
hallucinating information, saying things
like encryption and rotation, things
that aren't mentioned in the ticket at
all. We had to teach it to act more like
a security engineer, be okay with saying
I don't know, and that there's not
enough information rather than, of
course, hallucinating this information
to produce good output.
>> Great. Yeah, that's the end of our talk.
Thank you guys for listening.
Let's do some questions. I see Shriy.
>> Hi, thanks for the talk. Uh, I was
curious if accuracy was the only metric
that you used in your eval or did you
try other metrics as well?
So you said if accuracy was the only
metric
>> or did you try other metrics for scoring
in your evals as well?
>> Yeah, I think so specifically we use the
offline accuracy one um where it was you
know before the threat model or changes
to threat model agent were released um
we would base off of that. Um in the
next iteration and this is something
we're trying to build out is to give
more online evaluation. Right? So when a
threat model is done on a on a new
security review, how would it perform?
And the way we're thinking of
approaching this is you know
traditionally if it's a human um sort of
you know grading it that's great and all
but that involves like more security
process like you you would need all the
humans to do it um and that's not always
guaranteed. So what we're trying to
integrate is to have our security um
threat model tool that we mentioned
earlier as sort of the source of truth
and our threat model agent would
generate hey these are the threats that
um we found and users would use as a
source of truth to click approve sort of
deny and utilize those metrics to give
more of an online like feedback loop and
that would provide uh more accuracy. So
we're looking at you know from both
approaches.
Um, one question I had was have you guys
looked into like Maestro framework and
leveraging that as well as part of
because I think it's the Maestro
framework is uh like
specifically for AI scenarios
threat model uh it's a threat modeling
framework.
>> Sorry, can you repeat that one more
time? I'm wondering like if you took
into account or are thinking about
Maestro threat modeling framework into
account.
>> So the Maestro threat modeling
framework.
>> Maestro
>> um I think in that could be something we
build out in the future. I think for now
just building on our existing processes
most of it has been in the MITER format
but I think that format could go well
based on you know what sort of like risk
and security views we're seeing where it
could be more applicable.
You you said that you saw a 10%
reduction in accuracy in the threat
models coming out of that. Is that did I
understand that correctly?
>> Could you repeat the question? Sorry.
>> You said that you said that you saw a
10% reduction in accuracy in the threat
models that were being generated through
this. Did I hear that correctly?
>> The threat models that were being
generated through
>> through the the through this path.
>> Oh,
>> you said I I saw a 10% reduction in
accuracy. I'm curious, what level of
accuracy are you actually looking to
achieve before you put it into
production?
>> Oh, I think they're talking about the
JSON formatting that led to the 10%
reduction of the hyper.
>> Okay, I misunderstood. Maybe we'll we'll
come back afterwards and we can answer
that.